for two and a half years you may have
noticed official Washington has cracked
down hard on even minor violations of
the law Roger stone for example faces a
life-ending felony trial because he
apparently couldn't remember details
from a totally irrelevant email exchange
he once had while Manafort meanwhile I
was lucky to die behind bars in part
because he didn't file the right
paperwork before he lobbied for Ukraine
if you're involved in politics in
Washington suddenly there's not a lot of
room for error unless you happen to be a
Jim Comey if you're Jim Comey you can do
pretty much whatever you feel like it
you can fragrantly break the law and
then you can brag about it and nobody
will touch you how do we know this we
know this because Comey actually did
that shortly before he was fired from
the FBI Comey wrote memos describing his
private meetings with his boss the
president Comey then leaked those memos
some of them contain classified
information that is a crime how do we
know it's a crime well Comey himself
conceded that in an interview watch I
think of a leak as an unauthorized
disclosure of classified information
really I did that's all that's how I
thought about his FBI director
so by commis own definition which he
just heard he committed a crime come he
was responsible for the unauthorized
disclosure of classified information and
yet according to Comey
this was legal because it wasn't leaking
it was quote communicating but you did
leak you did leak memos I mean is it
okay for somebody at the FBI to leak
something an internal document even if
it's not classified isn't that leaking
well there's a whole lot wrong with your
question Anderson first I didn't leak
memos I asked a friend to communicate
the substance of one unclassified man
whether you okay one unclassified memo
to the media was it a leak I asked a
friend to communicate the contents of a
memo well it's a lie on multiple levels
and as it turns out the FBI has
determined that commis leaked memos did
in fact contain classified information
that Comey failed to redact keep in mind
this was the head of the FBI this is a
guy who knew what the rules were and
ignored them he
to crime Comey admits that he committed
that crime entirely for political
reasons when the president said he was
eager to find leakers and would like to
nail one to the doors a message I said
that shouldn't you be nail to the door
then I mean aren't you a leak aren't you
a leaker plenty of people leak non
classified information reporters and the
White House and the FBI gets upset about
it
the FBI gets upset when people make
unauthorized disclosures of protected
information I intentionally gave this
information to a friend intending that
it be out in the media
I wanted it together in the media I
wanted it to get out in the media a memo
with classified material in it what she
just saw is a confession come he
admitted everything on camera if you
were prosecuting this case it would be
open and shut but it won't be prosecuted
apparently Comey will never be tried for
the crimes he committed according to the
hills John Solomon setting a source the
DOJ has decided not to prosecute James
Comey on the grounds that punishing him
for breaking the law would seem quote
Petty and vindictive
of course petty and vindictive describes
the culture of the FBI under Jim Comey
petty and vindictive is the reason Roger
stone has been treated far more harshly
by federal authorities than Jeffrey
Epstein ever was petty and vindictive
sums up the entire Russia investigation
in fact an investigation that destroyed
people's lives for the crime of
supporting Donald Trump for president
petty and vindictive Jim Comey disgraced
the FBI he abused the public's trust in
him in 2016 he repeatedly injected
himself into the political arena and by
his own admission he considered the
political effect of his actions when he
did so his subordinates meanwhile people
like Peter struck and Lisa Paige
loathsome people repeatedly conspired to
use FBI resources to sabotage the
presidential campaign they didn't like
then in 2017 there was the climax of the
affair according to reports Comey lied
to the president his boss telling him
that he was not under investigation when
in fact Comey was maneuvering to begin
an investigation then with the leaks
that he just admitted to on-camera you
saw Comey launched the Russia
Special Counsel investigation from the
very beginning there's no evidence to
justify such an investigation there
never was rush occlusion was always just
a Hillary Clinton campaign talking point
an excuse for her humiliating election
defeat Comey knew that everyone who paid
attention knew that but instead of
behaving responsibly he indulged the
same conspiracy theory that seen in push
for two years
prosecuting Jim Comey for his crimes
crimes he's admitted to would not be
petty or vindictive just the opposite
might reassure the rest of us that
justice is in fact blind in this country
we're losing faith in that